[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Welcome back
to the "Next Live Show,"
I'm Stephanie Wong.
Joining us now is Jennifer Lind,
Product Management Director.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
JENNIFER LIN: Thanks
for having me.
STEPHANIE WONG: So for
those viewers who are just
learning about
Kubernetes and Borg,
can you explain what
each of those is,
and how we're making
Kubernetes easier to consume
and the significance of how
each has evolved at Google?
JENNIFER LIN: Sure.
Kubernetes is the
externalization
and the open source of our
internal controller development
container orchestration
tool called Borg.
It's something that we've
evolved over the last decade,
and we have said
publicly that we
launch four billion
containers a week
across the Google environment.
So managing that at
scale, we've learned a lot
about just running large
global scale systems
and doing container
orchestration at scale
in a resilient, reliable way.
Kubernetes was open
sourced a few years ago,
and we've had our own
managed version of Kubernetes
with Google Kubernetes
Engine now over four years.
So a lot has happened in a
very short period of time,
but there's lots of lessons
learned under the covers.
STEPHANIE WONG: We continue
to talk about API, services
and open source.
Why is Google differentiating
in this space?
JENNIFER LIN: Yeah, I think this
industry is changing so fast,
developers writing new software,
so it's really important
that we get the
interfaces and how
to enable the lifecycle
management of services
right as a system.
And I think that's why
Kubernetes has also gained
a lot of traction very quickly.
It sort of makes the notion of
a service a first class citizen.
And we've been very clear
about how do APIs interact,
and how do we essentially
define services
and do the lifecycle
management of services.
And that's all coming with
the maturity of things
like Kubernetes and Istio.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, and this
is all enabling our developers.
A lot of developers want to
approach the way that Google
does and dive in and
get experience the way
that Google develops software.
How does open source
enable the community
and empower the community?
JENNIFER LIN: Yeah,
I think open source
has been the reason why a lot
of this has moved so quickly.
I mean, it feels like
overnight it has become,
Kubernetes has become sort of
the container orchestration
system of choice.
Just a few years
ago, there were so
many, there was a lot of
fragmentation, a lot of folks
understood the value
proposition of containerization
with Docker.
But essentially managing that
at scale at the system level,
there were various options.
Through open source, I think
we've allowed a lot of people
to just, number one,
understand what's going on.
Number two, contribute in a
way that's meaningful for them.
And get a lot of the use
cases out there in the open,
so we can iterate on best
practices, et cetera.
And yes,--
A lot of this has been very
focused on developer agility,
but now as we move into
sort of the maturity of it,
yes, a lot of the practices for
the operational administrators
and SREs and making this
essentially a production level
system, is a lot of
what the community is
excited about as well.
STEPHANIE WONG:
That's great, yeah.
Open source is really
focused on our users.
And we also want to
build our user experience
into our products.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that?
And given that our cloud
users are different
and they have
different needs, how
do we build that into
our products as well?
JENNIFER LIN: Yeah, I mean, on
the product side within Google,
we do a lot with the
user research team
to just make sure we understand,
who are the personas,
whether it's
developer or security
administrator or a
network administrator
or the IT professional
or the user.
So just making sure we taking
sort of a use case driven
approach, and
understanding sort of who
is the user of the product.
And essentially, what problem
are they trying to solve?
And how do we hide
the complexity
and make it a lot easier?
And make sure that
they're essentially
doing their job well.
But there are a
lot, because this
is a software stack
with a lot of,
we've talked a lot about
decoupling and separation
of concerns.
You could have a
unified stack, but you
have to recognize that there's
lots of folks that essentially
are consumers of that stack.
STEPHANIE WONG: So what's
your advice for those
who want to move to the
Cloud with acceleration,
and not have to do
a rip and replace,
and manage their
existing lifecycle?
How do they bring
in Cloud Native?
JENNIFER LIN: Yeah, I think
Cloud Native has really
been about sort of openness
and the flexibility
that we talked about today
with Anthos is really,
there are an architectural
set of principles,
which I think Kubernetes
and things like Istio
have kind of put out there
in the open source community.
There's a framework.
And then there's
an implementation.
So number one, I think
the industry is really
rallying around the fact
that container orchestration,
there's sort of a clear
de facto standard there.
Obviously, we have our
managed version of that,
because there's a lot beyond
just the software bits in terms
of how do you actually
do lifecycle management
and keep essentially automatic
upgrades, patching, security
updates, et cetera, as
part of this system,
so that developers
can move quickly,
but you can keep essentially
the security and stability
of the system.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And one big part
of the acceleration
is GKE on prem, which was
announced last August.
And this is the first
time we've actually
brought our technology into
the data center at this scale.
So why now?
And why not sooner?
JENNIFER LIN: I
mean, what we found
is, everybody understands
the benefits of Cloud.
But in many cases, there's
technical and non-technical
reasons why they can't move
all their workloads into Cloud
overnight.
So this was a lot about bringing
the best of the Kubernetes
stack and what we're
doing with Google Cloud
to the on prem environment,
and helping people move
at their own pace.
While at the same time,
modernizing in place.
So it's not just about
renting compute cycles.
It's actually about
application modernization
and developing new
services and adding
more business value, et cetera.
So we're pretty
excited about that.
Now it's not just on
our GCP resources,
but we can essentially run
this on third party servers
in a private data center
for the enterprise.
And as we talked about today,
other environments as well.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
speaking of modernization,
we loved your demo during
the day one keynote.
JENNIFER LIN: Thank you.
STEPHANIE WONG: We heard a
lot about modernizing in place
this year.
Can you talk about
how Anthos enables
you to modernize
your applications,
no matter where they are, as
you mention, on premise or user
in the Cloud?
JENNIFER LIN: Yeah, I
think that's the nice thing
about Kubernetes
is, with Anthos,
we're really thinking
about sort of open APIs.
So that the interfaces between
those environments, number one,
we can hide the
complexity, but still
keep a consistent
management environment.
For the developers, independent
of where those workloads
run, they can learn
one set of tools
and essentially evolve
as the industry evolves
without picking sort of exactly
where that's going to run
or what production environment
it's going to run in,
because many
developers don't know.
They want to write
once, run anywhere.
Their consumers may be
running in many, many clouds.
And similarly for the
platform administrator,
they don't have to learn a
bunch of different vendor tools.
This framework is here to stay.
We believe it's going to be
the standard for many years
to come.
So even if that's not running
in Google's Cloud per se,
that skill set that
many enterprises
are trying to hire people who
understand Kubernetes, that's
very portable.
So people are willing
to invest in it now
because it's going to be
here to stay for many years.
STEPHANIE WONG:
And on that theme,
we're hearing that
developers and operators want
to be managing at higher
levels of the stack.
But they still want visibility
and control over policy
management at a service level.
How is Anthos providing a
unified programming model
and monitoring and policy across
on premise and multiple clouds?
JENNIFER LIN: Yeah,
great question.
I mean, with
Kubernetes obviously,
we've really thought about
container orchestration
and cluster
administration at scale.
With Istio, we're
thinking about assuming
most of your microservices
are now containerized,
how do you look out for
the lifecycle and health
of those services
and the interactions
between those services?
How do you make sure that those
services are authenticated
and that you can put essentially
policies around those services
without having to manage the
underlying infrastructure
complexity?
And then we showed
how we're doing
config management and automating
essentially configurations
at scale in a way that
essentially is declarative.
So you can define the policies
once and push them down
to different
environments, and you
don't have to rewrite
them with a lot of toil
for each cloud environment.
And that's really
important for customers
that are thinking about,
let's say, PCI compliance
or governance.
Those rules around how
to have those security
controls in place don't
change cloud to cloud.
But today, they're
spending a lot of time
just to make sure they can
ensure audit and compliance
in each different environment.
So we believe that's
sort of extra overhead
that doesn't need to
be there, and that
was a key push with Anthos.
Many of our
enterprise customers,
they want to embrace
new technologies,
but it's not easy
to figure out, how
do I ensure that I'm
still reducing my costs,
keeping the efficiency
and addressing
what the auditors and compliance
regulatory environments are
looking for?
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And we actually know
that not everybody
has the luxury of
moving to the cloud
immediately, for
whatever reason.
How can we help them get there?
JENNIFER LIN: Yeah, I think
a lot of it is, I mean,
this has been a
great week so far.
I think the partner
community is very engaged.
I think a lot of the use cases
and the best practices that
are being put out there
are based on folks
trying things out,
sharing best practices.
We're trying to take more of
a use case driven approach.
With Anthos, I think a lot
of what we're trying to share
is the operational
domain knowledge,
and the best practices of
us having run these systems
at scale.
But also tapping into our
hundreds of ecosystem partners
who are getting excited about
it and contributing back.
As this matures,
and I think this
is happening very quickly
in the last couple of years,
but it really is about
solution delivery and not
just technology delivery.
STEPHANIE WONG: With
Anthos, all these
customers moving into
production [INAUDIBLE]
skills, very exciting.
And obviously, as you said,
there are security concerns.
How are we making that
easier for our customers?
JENNIFER LIN: Yeah,
I mean we've been,
security is a major
differentiator for us for GCP
more broadly.
And I think because
containerization
is relatively a new space,
we've been doing a lot with both
our customers and partners
to do number one, education
and awareness round
container security
and secure software
supply chains
and things like binary
authorization and CICD,
and how to make sure
that security is baked in
way upstream,--
So that when a developer
checks in code,
essentially it starts the
governance process of security.
And it's not a bolt on
afterthought after the fact.
I think that is a lot of the way
that the Google developers are.
When they check in
code, essentially they
don't have to be an
expert in security,
but the platform takes care
of a lot of the complexity
of security and governance.
STEPHANIE WONG: Thank you so
much for your time, Jennifer.
JENNIFER LIN: Thanks
for having me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]